Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
There have been a number of reports
about Marvel using Doctor Strange.
3 as the final Marvel movie before
Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty in adapting.
Time runs out from the comics,
which was the final story
leading into the more recent version
of Marvel's Secret Wars, which we know
they're doing for Avengers 6.
So it all seems like it's coming together.
there are a lot of theories
about how Marvel was going to lead in
to Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars.
Now we know some of those details.
Marvel
making some changes to those storylines
for Doctor Strange three
so we'll break it all down
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Are we doing episodes
for Loki Season 2
When it starts, Ahsoka is starting
next week.
I'll be doing episode videos
for all that stuff Recently
you probably saw on your beads
Cosmic Circus.
Now a bunch of other websites
are reporting Doctor Strange three is
basically Marvel's time runs out
as in time runs out for the multiverse.
As the final incursions happen,
the multiverse begins to collapse.
The Council of Kangs come from
the New Avengers according to the reports.
Doctor Strange, three picks up right after
Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness
Post-Credits scene where Clea comes to get
Doctor Strange's help claiming
that he's caused another incursion
in what looks like the dark dimension.
basically
telling him he's coming to take with her
or she's going to kill him
like we're fixing it or else
they apply.
He's essentially going to be forced
to save dormammu light
by saving the dark dimension
from complete destruction.
how ironic.
Saving one of his worst
enemies, Clea is from the Dark dimension.
I did a much bigger video about her
after the movie
came out a couple of years ago,
so I'll post that in the links
below clears the daughter of the former
rulers of the dark
dimension
before Dormammu took over eons ago.
So she also has a bad history
with Dormammu too.
within the MCU.
One of the changes they're making for time
runs out is the CLEA will have been sent
by the MCU version of the Black Priest
from Time Runs Out, who she's working with
to stop the incursions
during the comic book
version of that storyline,
the black priests
were one of the major factions
trying to stop the incursions
and ultimately stop the beyonders
the Illuminati learned
about the incursions and separately Doctor
Strange learned about the black priests
and became their leader within the MCU.
This is sort of meant to pay off
that idea that Doctor Strange
went it alone in the 838 universe.
Like Doctor Strange himself is one of the
biggest threats to the entire multiverse.
basically the idea
that different versions of Doctor
Strange wound up making things worse,
even though they're trying
to save the multiverse within the MCU,
the black priest base is meant
to be kind of
like the TVA in that it exists outside
the main universes their base in Doctor
Strange three is meant to exist in
something called nothing space,
which they're calling the area
left by the destroyed universes
after incursions are over.
Similar to what you see in Doctor
Strange Supreme's Universe
in Multiverse of Madness.
kind of like an empty shell of a universe
with leftover bits all over the place.
We'll see other incursions
actually happen.
Teased in other Marvel movies before this.
We're supposed to get some of that
during the Marvel's movie later this year.
Like an actual incursion
where two universes start to collide
with each other.
but. Doctor Strange
three is supposed to be the movie.
Will they do the longer explain
like the PowerPoint tutorial that Doctor
Strange will learn about the incursions
in great detail
and how they destroyed the multiverse
clarifying that he did
cause the most recent one,
which Clea was talking
about during that post-credits scene.
you can also kind of blame
Scarlet Witch for that too they're saying
that her use of the Darkhold chaos
magic in combination with America.
Chavez's power in Doctor
Strange is to breach different universes.
Also mind walking the souls of the damned
from the hell dimension
like finger puppets.
destabilize this part of reality,
causing an incursion.
So within the movie Doctor
Strange will be confronted
with one of the main points of Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness,
that he himself
is one of the greatest threats
to the multiverse itself,
even though he's trying to save everyone.
the only greater threat to the multiverse.
And this is sort of the stand
in for the MCU version.
The borders will be the Council of Kangs
in the new Cain Multiverse War 2.0.
As teased in Ant-Man,
the Wasp Quantumania.
part of the idea is that they're sort
of taking the place of the comic book
Beyonders role in Time
runs out in the lead up to secret wars
they kind of explained how the Kang
Multiverse War was responsible
for all these different incursions.
When he who remains told Loki and Sylvie
about how he won the first version
of the multiverse war,
basically by finding a life
and having him consume
all the other timelines except his own.
they didn't say that a Kang variant
is going to be the main villain.
A doctor.
Strange three, but they'll probably
at least feature one came to clarify
what the Council of Kangs is doing
and how this leads into Avengers five,
probably a big post-credits scene
like we saw during Thor Ragnarok
within Infinity War. Post-Credits scene.
there might be some more references
to the comic book
version of Time runs out in the comics.
There were several different factions
all warring with each other
the same way that they're doing
in the MCU.
Just different people
representing those organizations.
originally it was Doctor
Strange as black priests
who ended up fighting the Black Swans,
led by Dr.
Doom and the Ivory Kings,
who were actually the billionaires.
Dr. Doom and Doctor Strange separately
had no idea that the other was leading
separate armies, both of their groups
were strategically destroying universes
on purpose with the hope that it would
stop the incursions like a controlled
burn of the multiverse, to stop a larger
fire from erasing everything.
But at least initially.
Doctor Strange, his group was destroying
universes that Dr.
Doom's group was protecting.
So they fought each other
until they realized
that they were both trying
to accomplish the same goal
and work together.
Doctor Doom in typical fashion,
did the most Dr.
Doom thing ever tricking a multiverse
team of black swans
into worshiping him as a religious figure.
you start to see some of the seeds
of what he became when he turned into God.
Emperor Doom
by about a world in secret wars.
really loves it
when people worship him as a God.
the real threat was from the Ivory Kings,
who were actually
the builders, the ones responsible
for the incursion in the first place.
They were a group of extra
dimensional beings with almost limitless
power,
not bound by the normal laws of reality.
that basically got tired of the multiverse
and just wanted to wipe out
all of reality, supposedly Avengers
six Secret wars is going to combine
both different versions, different eras
of secret works like the 1980s version
in the more modern version.
the Easter egg here for the 1980s
version, Is it the Beyonder who pulled
a bunch of characters to battle world
to compete for his entertainment?
Marvel eventually retconned it
so that that version of the Beyonder
was actually just a baby version
of the Beyonders race that they wind up
fighting in the more recent version
of the Secret Wars, supposedly in the MCU,
though,
they're going to say that beyonder
character is actually just another Kang
variant with crazy levels of power,
maybe the one that survived
at the end of Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania
that everyone thought died.
this sort of gets into Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty in the lead
up to Avengers six Secret Wars.
Supposedly the idea
is that the new Avengers that form
invite the Council of Kangs in Avengers
five will not be able to defeat them
like they'll wind up getting their asses
handed to them.
it'll mostly be the MCU version
of new Avengers
characters, like characters
you see in the Marvel movies so far.
Then apparently what Kevin Bucky is doing
is sort of like a final sendoff
to the Marvel Fox characters,
like all the legacy actors, this other
beyonder-like Kang will come back
and kill the Council of Kangs.
Like who can kill a Kang but another Kang.
he'll be the one to create battle world
and they'll be a bunch of remnants
of universes with these legacy Fox Marvel
characters from different universes.
All left on this one planet.
Doctor
Strange is supposed to be a main character
during both Avengers
five and Avengers six.
Like the rallying point
that brings everyone together.
So in Avengers six, he has to go around
assembling a multiverse team
of all the greatest characters
into a new Avengers.
They'll be the ones to finally defeat
this last kang beyonder character.
And then they'll rebuild the multiverse.
Kind of like happened at the end
of the newer version of Secret Wars.
There's been a lot of rumors about Marvel
using Secret
wars, the soft reboot, the universe,
but the whole idea is
that they'll try to retune things
just a little bit to explain
how a bunch of X-Men and mutants
start popping up all over the place.
They might recast some characters
if they want to.
Not everybody,
but maybe a couple of people
maybe retune the back
story of the universe a little bit
so that it all makes a little more sense
going forward and because they're
calling Marvel Phase four or five and six
the multiverse saga, the next big saga
that they started, Marvel Phase seven
will be kind of like the Mutant Saga,
very X-Men focused Saga,
which is why they've been waiting
so long to do really hard
core X-Men characters like Deadpool three.
We'll see a bunch of X-Men,
but as part of a final sendoff
for a lot of the classic versions
of the actors before they recast people
with new versions in the MCU.
we're not for all the delays
like the pandemic delays and everything
that's happened
recently with the strikes on those delays,
we actually would have seen this on screen
years and years ago.
given, but it's a long time ago.
He's really keen to introduce
a bunch of X-Men characters,
but it's just sort of like a one thing
right after the other,
like he has to do a lot of stuff
before he can do that
but you can see how they're slowly
setting up all these big legacy actors
coming back like Tobey Maguire,
Spider-Man, Andrew Garfield, Spider-Man.
That was what all those scenes
in Spider-Man No Way Home were about.
Like, Oh, you know,
I really want to fight an alien.
Hey, we should do this again sometime.
doing this again some time in secret wars.
the bit a lot of rumors about them.
Also splitting secret wars into
two different films. We'll see about that.
I think it just depends on what happens
in the next couple of years.
We're still a couple of years out
from secret wars happening at all.
Anyway, they'll start to set up
what's going on during
Loki season two and then obviously
Deadpool three in a much, much bigger way.
there were a couple of Loki season two
trailer videos that I just did videos for.
So I'll post links at the end of this
and then the description below
kind of explaining
what's happening during that.
They'll have their own plot,
but in the background,
the Kang Multiverse Ward,
the Council of Kangs
will also be doing their thing.
The incursions will start to happen.
Big reminder
that Ahsoka episodes start next week.
I'll post links for that
down to the description below.
Click here
for all my brand new Loki Trailer videos
and click here for my brand new Deadpool
3 videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!